[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
jusqu'à quand pourrons-nous dévaler les
pentes enneigées à toute vitesse à quoi
ressembleront nos stations de ski dans
les années à venir le ski alpin est-il
bientôt condamné avant de répondre à ces
questions retour dans les années 70
[Musique]
les cinq stations qui composent le
complexe de métabieie Mondor
c'est-à-dire Jung les hôpitaux neufs les
longes villes les rôles gens ont donc
connu pour ses vacances de fin d'année
une affluence que les pessimistes
n'espérez pas on n'avait pas vu cela
depuis des dizaines d'années aux Rousses
et malgré l'altitude de 1100 à 1600
mètres de la neige depuis septembre et
sans interruption de quoi réjouir tous
les amateurs de sports d'hiver monsieur
comment discuter cette saison pour vous
très bien
vous êtes optimiste pour le reste de la
saison oui on a toujours eu de la neige
il y en aura un
de la neige il y en aura toujours pas si
sûr observons ce Candice les
prévisionnistes de Météo France
prenons le top 10 des épaisseurs de
neige à mouth dans le houx on le voit
clairement depuis l'an 2000 un seul
record d'enneigement a été battu c'était
en 2015
si en parallèle on place les épaisseurs
maximales de ces cinq dernières années
on se rend bien compte que la neige se
fait de plus en plus rare
et si on se projette dans l'avenir le
constat n'est pas plus réjouissant Météo
France livre deux scénarios la optimiste
si nous changeons nos modes de vie et
l'autre pessimiste si rien ne change
dans les deux cas et c'est
particulièrement flagrant sur le
scénario pessimiste l'épaisseur du
manteau neigeux chute à partir de 2030
en fait dans le Jura le Léman le plus
marqué c'est le réchauffement hivernal
si on fait la moyenne en janvier février
mars chaque année depuis 2009 on
s'aperçoit que depuis l'an 2000 on a
probablement dépassé les plus quatre
degrés voire près de 5 degrés en plus
pour ces trois mois d'hiver c'est moins
vrai pour les autres mois de l'année
mais pour les mois d'hiver on a ce
réchauffement qui est extrêmement brutal
rapide et très élevé et ça c'est quelque
chose évidemment qui va impacter la vie
quotidienne et qui va impacter
évidemment de façon majeure
le fonctionnement du tourisme hivernal
dans le Jura c'est-à-dire
essentiellement le ski le ski de fond on
pourra en faire mais voilà ça sera deux
semaines dans l'année parce qu'il y a de
la neige parce que économiquement c'est
évidemment beaucoup moins coûteux de
faire du ski de fond le ski de piste lui
nécessite toute une série de normes de
sécurité qui font qu'il faut dépenser
beaucoup d'argent pour le faire tenir et
donc les gens j'ai envie de dire quand
on en parlait il y a encore 5 ans
les gens nous croyaient pas
ce qui est inquiétant c'est le déni des
hommes politiques des grands acteurs des
stations de ski quand je dis grands
acteurs je parle du syndicat
professionnel des remontées mécaniques
je parle du syndicat des moniteurs de
ski je parle de l'Association des Maires
je parle de beaucoup de conseils
municipaux la façon dont on a équipé les
montagnes pour pratiquer le ski tel
qu'on le connaît aujourd'hui en gros les
vacances au sport d'hiver tels que
décrite figés par le film Les Bronzés
c'est une invention des années 60 avant
ça en pratique elle le ski différemment
dans des lieux différents c'était pas
tout à fait les mêmes stations
on s'y déplaçait pas de la même manière
on ce qui est pas pareil donc en fait je
suis je suis extrêmement optimiste parce
que
parce qu'il reste tout à inventer il
reste à s'adapter il reste à imaginer
comment on va profiter de la montagne
demain imaginez des choses nouvelles
certains acteurs de la montagne de le
faire dans notre région et notamment
dans le Haut-Doubs un grand coloc
européen a eu lieu à métabie en mars
2021 pour aborder concrètement la
question du changement climatique dans
nos montagnes depuis cet événement la
station de Métabief a les yeux des
spécialistes braqués sur elle
ces exploitants se sont donnés une année
butoire 2035 date à laquelle le ski
alpin pourrait selon eux avoir disparu
dans le massif du Jura
prenons la direction de Métabief pour
rencontrer Olivier rare l'un des
artisans de cette transition
[Musique]
le postulat c'est d'anticiper une fois
un potentiel du ski cours de la décennie
2030 2040 le modèle du ski alpin sur la
moyenne montagne c'est presque un des
premiers modèles à être touché par
vraiment par le changement climatique
parce que là la montagne se réchauffe
deux fois plus vite que le reste et en
plus l'Europe se réchauffe deux fois
plus vite que le reste du monde donc en
gros la moyenne montagne européenne
c'est presque la plus impactée dès 2014
la station a entamé une réflexion
approfondie quant à son avenir avec un
objectif effectuer la transition la
moins douloureuse possible pour tenter
d'y répondre en 2019 un pull Ingénierie
est créé au sein du Syndicat Mixte du
Mont d'Or il est financé grâce à la taxe
remontée mécanique
la station de ski de Métabief se prépare
à devenir une station de montagne
souvent les stations quand elles parlent
de transition en fait elle parle de
diversification c'est les tyrolienne
c'est on le VTT nous là et on regrette
pas d'avoir c'est évident bah voilà on
essaye d'imaginer tout un tas
d'activités hors ski qui puisse si
possible être desservé par les remontées
mécaniques pour que derrière on ait les
mêmes équipements qui fassent à la fois
du ski hors ski mais économiquement
c'est c'est pas ça n'a pas le même
volume et le même poids que le ski si on
doit arrêter le ski sur le périmètre qui
nous concerne en fait on n'arrivera pas
à compenser
l'économie du tourisme dans le
Haut-Doubs repose à 50% sur l'activité
de Métabief et le ski alpin représente
90% des recettes de Métabief les enjeux
sont donc particulièrement complexes
d'autant que la diversification des
activités ne peut se faire à n'importe
quel prix pour respecter la biodiversité
le syndicat par exemple fait le choix de
renoncer à tout projet d'aménagement
touristique artificialisé sur le massif
du Mont d'Or on a un vrai jardin
botanique sur la montagne nous on est
une moyenne montagne mais à 1400 mètres
en fait le fait qu'on soit au nord vous
avez encore des Pelous subalpines donc
on a des étages écologiques qui sont
hyper riches donc en gros même si on
voulait réglementairement et
heureusement on pourrait pas donc on a
fait aussi ce deuil là de se dire bah
non il y aura pas 10000 activités horney
sur le massif c'est pas possible il y a
pas de solution toute faite les
solutions sont à inventer et la
meilleure manière de faire c'est de
coopérer coopérer coopérer avec de la
méthode de la bienveillance de la
confiance et ça ça se décrète pas c'est
comme les l'amour ça il y a que des
preuves d'amour donc des preuves de
confiance etc etc donc continuer quand
même à mettre de l'ingénierie là-dedans
parce qu'on est quand même sur quelque
chose qui va prendre quelques années à
être mature à être à fonctionner tout
seul mais on y croit si dans 10 ans le
ski continue ben tant mieux parfait on
aura ça sera la cerise sur le gâteau si
ça doit s'arrêter a priori on devrait ça
devrait se passer moins dans la douleur
que si ça avait été subi c'est un pari
qu'on fait mais en tout cas voilà c'est
le pari qu'on fait vous l'aurez compris
il est impossible de savoir aujourd'hui
à quoi ressemblera le tourisme dans le
massif du Jura dans 10 15 ou 20 ans une
chose est sûre les territoires de
montagne ne sont pas que des lieux de
divertissement alors des grands
bouleversements leur mutation est
indispensable c'est ce que nous explique
pour conclure fionami de l'OMG
internationale Mountain walderness qui
milite depuis 30 ans pour la sauvegarde
de la montagne il y a une prise de
conscience qui est évidente qui est
d'autant plus frappante cette année mais
qui avait déjà été amorcé quand même
l'an dernier avec la crise du covid
après il y a une inquiétude et l'enjeu
justement cette transformer cette
inquiétude en envie de d'agir en fait
transformer une inquiétude à un désir
d'autres choses et je pense que les
territoires de montagne ils ont assez de
richesses justement pour pour rebondir
et inventer quelque chose de souhaitable
pour chacun de ces territoires donc non
on souhaite vraiment participer à cette
dynamique là qui est justement de
réfléchir à de nouveaux modèles
économiques à de nouvelles manières de
vivre en montagne pour montrer que bah
oui même si il y a un fort
ralentissement de l'activité du ski ça
ne veut pas dire que c'est la fin des
montagnes loin de là
[Musique]